so we'll see what happens with tyler
it's great to see him get a quick out on
the first pitch there's a lot in play
here
i think the other thing too that's
important scott said this last night on
the post game show is that he also told
you say that the team wouldn't be in the
position they're in without the first
half that he had swing and a miss
first strikeout tonight for tyler
anderson
a second batter to swing at the first
pitch
and make it out crawford over to make
the catch could not ask for a better
start to this one for tyler anderson
scoreless going to the bottom of the
first
chris bassett for the second outing in a
row
going to be staring down the seattle
mariner squad
remember last time three solid innings
just one hit
this is lace down the left field line
and a fair ball into the corner extra
bases for jp crawford flying into second
base and he stands up for the lead-off
double what a year he has had he came
into the game hitting 272 overall
bases are loaded
second walk in the inning
abraham toro toro
at 239 with ted homer's 45 rbis
toro
shallow pop
here comes brown crawford tagging
crawford's gonna try to score here comes
the throw to the plate it's there the
tag got him
so seth brown
on a shallow pop-up makes a very nice
throw to the plate and the a's keep the
mariners off the board
so nicely done by brown throws out
crawford at the plate worth another look
in the game final before first pitch
here tonight
swinging a miss top of the zone second
strikeout for tyler anderson
off man retired here's marcano
fought off and it's inside the bag it
sneaks fair
canna makes a turn hannigan plays it off
the wall here comes the throw a strike
the tag
and they got him at second base
what a peg by mitch haniger
well there's a couple of things on this
first of all how about this inside out
swing he's completely fooled on this
pitch fights it off stays inside the
back henry gets over there and he does
the right thing when he feels it he's
going to spin so he gets some momentum
and he cranks it up
and then the pick and the tag by jp
crawford another one too
routine pop up on the infield
anderson is uh
gonna make the catch he did it he joins
the mariners club
i'll take care of this
[Music]
astros are 47 and 26 so not a whole lot
of difference within the division
her feet toward the corner canna looks
like he's got room and he does and he
makes the catch
runner left we're on to inning number
three no score
the game is even or if there's one run
either way i would not be surprised to
see him come in and pitch to the sixth
inning either way just to hold it there
soft sinking little pop-up takes a funny
hop toro
and he's out at first base harrison a
headlong slide but he is out at first
pitch number eight to crawford
clubs it down the line into right field
and this short hops the wall it's
another extra base hit for jp crawford
he slides in with his second double
tonight
well his first double down the left
field line comes right back looks like
another cutter in the middle of the play
this one is able to square up short hops
the fence trying to bring that runner in
and he does drive on the other way
pinned her a long run and pender reaches
out and makes the catch
crawford's going to tag crawford's going
to try for third and he'll make it
tony kept waiting
he's got it so bassett gets out of it
again he got out of a jam in the first
same thing here in the third no score
after three
top of the fourth hitting nice job by
chris bassett working out of a couple of
jams in this game
ender hits that ball well to center
kelnick back kelvinic at the wall he
leaps and that baby's gone a's lead
one-nothing
number five for pender that had to feel
good sure did
chad pinder gonna swipe right on a
little change-up kite because he likes
it
pack your bags cheap pender all aboard
next stop
pound town
five six and seven hitters in the
mariners lineup
got him swinging took a little off
that's the first strikeout for bassett
so that is gonna do it
three in the third innings tonight
for chris bassett and he's gonna leave
with the runner at first you have one
out braley with one out and two on
lined into right field this will tie it
up if not more here comes counting
terrains he's getting waved home luis
terrence headed home the tag
and the is
have taken the lead
jake fraley stands up at third it's a
2-1 mariners lead in the bottom of the
fourth inning
hopping to toro shin high routine toss
to first two runners left stranded the
mariners maintain the lead through four
and a half
[Applause]
strike three call
casey sadler carving through the a's
tonight
runners on the corners two guns
murphy's splits diving stop harrison
and the pick is not made toro is in
fraley first to third
the mariners get
a two-run lead now thanks to tom murphy
harrison made a great diving stop on it
but the play wasn't completed olson one
of the best in the business at first
base normally i would say he's going to
come up with that picket but he just
whips it
is one for
two there's a line drive base hit right
field
here comes canna throw to the plate is
cut off but it's a three to two game
well i'll remind you of the final game
of the series in oakland where the
mariners
swept the a's it was mitch haniger
homering off of diekmann to tie the game
does he get him again does he get him
again he does
it's the series of mitch henniger
congratulations to him his 100th career
home run and a fantastic milestone
outstanding
two outs chapman at first
out to center kellneck calneck a
galloping catch the mariners win again
and the mariners are still in the fight
you